living on a date where a woman's offered
to pay no
not not in the day what was that laugh
about what was that laugh all about
because I actually had this conversation
with my vision about the whole painting
and I had to let it know like you're my
bridging you know like you can go harder
you can pay for yours you know like she
was a girlfriend no she was a girl who
was a friend yeah yeah right okay so
that's it I was having a talk about nah
yeah um unless we're in a relationship
like yeah no females actually paid or
even offered to go and pay is it weird I
feel like when I say I I feel like
um I've had a I've had a I've had an
incident
um with a woman who made a lot I would
but on date a woman who made a lot of
money like she was like a like a hedge
fund individual she was only like 200k
right like a month like 200k a year like
oh she was making good money more money
than I was making you know what I'm
saying and I and I specifically remember
it's a great day you know great girl and
you know the bill came at the end of the
night right and I kind of had my jacket
on the chair and my wallet and my jacket
right and I just went okay cool what I
kind of bent down to kind of get my
wallet out and she just took her phone
and went
and paid like the guy and I was like the
[ __ ] are you doing and she was like oh
well I'm just paying and I was like are
you trying to [ __ ] emasculate me or
some [ __ ] like on the day and she and
the thing is in her head she was like no
like I'm just used to kind of like pain
because I make money and then the thing
is
listen I had no problem with the girl
but I just said that the mindset
I was just like that's gonna be a
problem now but that's gonna be a
problem that's the thing about when
she's with our virgins they do the same
thing so the fact that she's got her on
a date it's the same type of vibe like
that's that's brilliant that's beautiful
now for me it would be a problem because
then it's like I don't want anybody
having like something over me like that
I don't want a woman having that over
then you've got the next one what if she
doesn't make more money but she just
wanted to treat you
it'd probably be different
because
she's doing it for a treat not just
because her Persona is I pay was it was
it was it more hurt no I mean was it
more her attitude about it no her
attitude was I'm telling you her
attitude was fine she she was just in a
mindset that she just used to paying for
everything and so for me if you're in
that mindset of you're just used to
paying for everything it's going to be a
problem me and you were going to battle
in this relationship if if it goes
further down the line because I'm just
gonna be like okay cool I don't want to
be battling with you with you know who
pays for stuff like I just don't I don't
want that right now
out of 10. no no don't do that I have a
question no I'm not saying that she's
not a cool girl but I'm saying that hey
if she was like super model you wouldn't
leave because she paid for a and b if if
she if she was if she was a supermodel
would she offer to pay no um the way my
mind works is I try to look further down
the road at things and my whole thing is
you could be a 10 out of 10 in looks
yeah but if I'm looking to get into a
relationship with you I'm trying to see
the things within the relationship that
are going to school Court calls like a
Schism within a relationship and I know
that would have caused a Schism that
would have pissed me off so I'm just
like it's not even really worth it but
what's your turn though
she was a she was a nice looking girl
let's see let's just say that she was a
nice looking girl I don't go on dates
with whales
just saying for the guys now if you say
you
um you're dating somebody and they got
to the club for their birthday and they
bring all their girls and everything do
you think
because this is I've seen this in a
video where she brought her girl to the
date no no it's not a date Club
celebrate you and her and then her girls
are out of the club do you think you are
obligated to pay for her stuff and her
friends stuff like drinks and stuff at
the club well for her birthday for her
birthday what I'm obligated to do is pay
for you so I if seriously over the club
then I'll put money for the bucket your
bridges are out for you for your
birthday so as your virgins when you
don't know me go out and I'm not there
y'all be paying for your [ __ ] right so
then the rest of them put in I'll put in
the center percentage because you're my
girl I'm out here with you but they have
to be put in I'm gonna cover it for them
as well they can go home otherwise we
can go out with my guys and oh my guys
they'll all cover the whole set for you
we will have a late night depends how
expensive it is irrelevant it's not
their birthdays no but it's like a
birthday party you're setting up in it
it's like you know what I mean
anything expensive if you've got enough
money how do you guys feel about paying
ladies
like would you go 50 50 with a guy are
you okay with that I usually pay for the
guys too like are you applying for
things like I always get something to
somebody you know coffee or whatever
snack there you go take it
yeah it's like a thing you know when
you're together in a group or whatever
or with your
boyfriend or something I don't mind
paying like but I've had the same
similar
um
thing where I went up and paid and he
was like
you know he got he kind of had to tell
me like that he stopped kind of going
out with me because he didn't like me
paying and when he didn't have enough
money and I was earning money he would
still not go out with me because he
really he just she didn't like yeah
anyway in my thing in my instance when
that happened it wasn't a pride thing
because like I said when she done that I
said listen please just don't do that
again because it was an emasculating
experience and it seemed like another
pride thing no but I said it I don't
think it came from a malicious place
when she'd done it you know what I mean
it was just for me I just thought
you didn't even say anything you just
thought yeah there you go it's done and
I'm just like I don't like I didn't like
it oh maybe she does it because she
doesn't want the awkward moment of you
saying should we go horse because she's
got she's got enough money so she could
just ended the whole this is what I'm
saying she could just end the whole
issue of that just by paying for it
but you took the wrong react like not
the wrong reaction but you had the no
she liked it afterwards
laughs I'm not saying anything
that was paid
all right well yeah me I mean like I
don't really go dating because of these
kind of situations because I feel like
it's forcedent how are you gonna get
your whys if you don't go deep you know
what I'm saying there's not anyways
well personally as well for me I feel
like
I don't know if it's just me but
sometimes just paying and sharing the
guy that you're not like there for the
money or you're like oh you can pay for
yourself I don't know for me personally
I just felt that guys might like that
but I don't know no I'm saying if you
can't if you can't if you can listen if
you can't pay for a date why are you
going on a date
yeah as a man
it's true but then but then where does
the equality kick in though that's
that's what I'm wondering for like women
like women say they want equality and
you know they want you know to be equal
with men like where does that kick in on
a date I'm just kind of laid back like I
don't know like if he wants split it we
can I don't care like if he doesn't okay
you won't see him any differently if he
wants to split the split the day
don't cap
no I mean okay okay I think it's
appreciated but I still I understand the
fact that like you know traditional
women like get courted traditionally and
I think if you're not like 22 and a
virgin you're not traditional so it's
kind of like we're asking to be courted
like traditional women but we're not
anymore so I kind of understand where
the guys are coming from I'm just I
don't know I'm laid back I think if I
like the guy he can probably get away
with it so do you think it's worse do
you think it's worse yeah check this out
do you think it's worse if he can't
afford it and you pay for him or he
can't afford it and you pay for him
I said splints that pay for him but
um if he can't it's worse if he can't
afford it I can't if first he can't
afford it yeah yeah of course uh yeah
what do you mean so if he could afford
it I'm just being honest all things
equal if one guy has money and one guy
doesn't have money like women are more
attracted to the guy with money yeah
yeah like all things being equal yes
but as for the first date I do believe
that the man not supposed to but it
would be actually supposed to pay for
the woman's meal for the first time
to me I would just think he's not into
me you know what I mean like he doesn't
want to pay for you yeah like because to
me if a guy really likes a girl he's not
gonna let her pay how about I'm testing
you yeah I was gonna say the same thing
used to the disappointment over and over
again where Gala just using them for the
first date yeah yeah it's like no on the
on the fifth day now we can start
talking about spending a little money
not about on Thursday I just met you
guys that's what I'm saying I get it so
that's what I said I'm pretty laid back
I don't think I'd really hold it over
his head if you like the guy I'm sorry
he doesn't have to spend money on you
and I stand by this I've seen I've seen
like guys say that to test a woman right
you go out on a date and you you know
you you get the meal and then you say oh
damn I forgot my wallet and then see if
she says oh that's okay I can pay for it
and then if she says that he's like okay
don't worry I was just yeah I'll pay for
it is that not the correct answer no
because some women are like well I ain't
man you better go wash some dishes or
some [ __ ] you know what I'm saying that
just lets you know where mindset is and
what right yeah I've heard I just don't
think it's that big of a deal like early
on let's just see how where it goes I
don't know on the first on the first
date I'll ask like oh like do you want
to split it because I don't want the man
to assume like oh you're supposed to be
paying for it did he ask you out though
if he asked you out on a date shouldn't
he be paying nah not see that I don't
agree with you I assume because then
it's like they have to assume that
they're gonna pay for everything it's
just like I don't want that to be
something that you automatically assume
whenever you take a female out like
you're you have to pay so that's why I
asked like do you want to split it I
mean I'm 41 in it I'm just like
different gen
I'm just like if I ask a woman out on a
date I'm gonna pay but it's a funny
thing with the testing people you know
like if the men testing women so it's
like exactly the same with the women as
well it's like if he's gonna appear or
no if like he's gonna appear on the
first date it's like you know what
actually that's like the guy like in
general there's like it's a plus in the
way because he asks you out it's the
first time
and come approach you and be like hey
let's go out so naturally because you
have to be the guy and go forward and do
what the man's supposed to do you have
to ask them out
no you don't think I don't get so after
the after the first day if she said hey
like would you like to like go what was
the first day first day was the park
right
whatever you guys
this is a Vibe especially in the
summertime yeah
what if she asks you out to dinner like
hey like if you're not doing anything
this weekend let's go out to dinner
which is she obligated to pay then or is
it you still have to pay since you're no
you asked me to come up but listen yeah
I'll be front that day
yeah because I'm thinking about me
making sure that I got for me because
you asked me so now I definitely have to
make sure that I got jealous done like I
don't know okay do you guys feel like
you go up more above and beyond if you
like a girl more of course yeah of
course so of course a girl a girl a
captain so okay okay a girl that you're
really okay okay
a girl that you're really into that you
feel like maybe is punching a little bit
for you I feel bad when you do okay
would you ask her to split it
I keep saying it depends because it's
like this yeah if she's got pee and like
you see it you say how you say you you
forgot your wallet and she she said no
don't worry I got it so it's like so why
wasn't you able to go horse with it
anyway
any kind of sense like why why did you
have to wait for me to do it before we
the discussion is that we're going
Horrors on this like why do we have to
have this discussion whether or not we
go halves or IP or whatever that's why I
don't go dating because it's like too
much pressure on that sense do you
remember that thing I told you about
from that yeah it's pretty gorgeous
gorgeous dude we had that thought
beforehand that yo like listen we're
going out to eat where do you want to go
she suggested World Cup I said oh I like
that I've been there a couple times it's
a bit more Japanese place um
anyway we shouldn't be proponent yeah we
ain't got no money from them so this
this is something that she suggested so
I'm not all right cool but you know it's
a bit pricey she's like oh I didn't know
so I just sent her the many prices that
I've took him on my phone like you know
like this what's on the menu these are
the prices for the for the stuff you
understand cool but watch this so we've
understood what it is from the beginning
so if you still want to go there know
that there's is how much it costs I'm
also going to let you know cap but I'm
going to let you know that my financial
situation is a bit Ticky this week
Netflix bills a car I don't know so on
and so forth is coming out just to see
what then what you're actually going to
be do you understand I feel like that
talk has to happen beforehand otherwise
you're gonna get there and I'm not a
fool I will look you dead in your eye
and slap my piano and be like the food
was nice I enjoy here so you tried to go
for dates
you would just put half your money down
and then go
you can't just expect because I can't
just expect so you can't just expect and
if you do that's an insult to me I'm my
idea I might assim it's not gonna happen
so yeah slide down my heart and go back
I just feel like wow I kind of I'm gonna
stand on this I feel like if you had a
girl that you were really into you would
not ask you wouldn't do that I feel like
these are kind of girls that you're like
ah maybe and if a girl is kind of uh
you're not taking her to Rocco bro yeah
but you're testing us you're not taking
it to hakasan you ain't taking that to
know
McDonald's you're testing it even more
now because because now you're you're
you're having a battle of yourself I
agree if she suggested the restaurant I
could see where you're coming from but
like I feel like if you really like a
girl you're trying to impress her I
didn't say other ways yeah food is like
paying for food or painful stuff in
general is not one of them you know like
there's so much things that we can do
for free around London that I'll pay for
Uber if that's the case I'll pay for
Uber we can do other bits and pieces we
can spend time going to look at tandem
bikes and whatnot there's things you can
do that don't cause peas like that no I
I agree with you but I'm like why would
you invite her somewhere and then ask
her to split it no no I didn't buy it
that's what I'm saying I feel like on a
first date if you liked a girl you would
try to impress her so if you didn't want
to do the dinner you could do something
free that's still fun like you'd still
want to impress her right or you just
don't want to impress women you like but
then as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible